come and see what everyone's talking
about he's been to you assalamu alaikum
welcome to the Deen show I'm Eddie your
host and today we're going to be giving
you the top 5 reasons proofs let's back
it up a little bit you've already gotten
sick of all the Hollywood and Bollywood
the rated-r movies and going to the
nightclubs and you've attained so much
money or you couldn't make the money or
you got a position you lost a girl you
lost to all this other drama dilemmas of
life and your self there's got to be
more there's got to be a purpose to life
so you you went from this ISM to that
ISM you studied all the world religions
and now you finally came to Islam and
the bedrock of Islam is calling you to
you want to accept Islam and hopefully
God willing at the end of the show
you're going to accept this snob you
already accept what's in your very
nature intrinsically embedded in you
that there's only one God not for 3 & 1
1 & 3 and God being a man and the Sun
and all these other things God
everywhere and you and me and we're all
God this all this nonsense below the
things just don't make sense it's not
adding up one is one and you keep it at
one and you only worship the one who
created you the same God of Jesus Moses
Abraham and the last final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him they
all worship the One God and that's the
first part of accepting Islam that you
negate all the false gods you say that
there's no God except the One God the
creator of all that exists in Arabic
Allah Jesus spoke Aramaic Aramaic he
said Aloha and then you testify the same
way that you would during jesus's time
if you were living that Jesus was the
Messenger of God
during Moses time that Moses is the
mushrooms guy and now during our time
there's no God except the one true God
the creator of all that exists and
Muhammad is the messenger the final
prophet sent by God no more messages to
come but how do you know that he was
indeed a messenger that's what we're
going to be covering in this week's show
we're going to be giving you the top 5
proofs that he indeed was so after the
show you can take that step the
necessary step that you need to take to
become one who submits to God a Muslim
when we come back here and again show
sit tight this is
13 the teacher this is the thesis theme
this is the thing you know this is the
things the theme this is the theme so
I'm like on peace be with you
you can still a look at me peace be unto
you - and we're wishing peace upon each
others we start with peace you know but
many people don't have peace they're
frustrating like they got money but
peace is something that you can't buy
you cannot buy a six-pack of peace so
how do you get PJ a peace of mind is
when you're actually at wrinkle with one
itself and one one God and that's what
got on my - image in the Quran this is
what the piece how today never be
victory let top my end uncle OOP
by the remembrance of God Almighty that
your heart is at ease and certainly
insha'Allah you will find peace with
Islam so when you when you know the
purpose of life you know why you've been
created where you came from where you're
going when you die and is this how you
can have that peace this is of course I
answering these questions yes God
Almighty actually gives you the answer
the questions he's the only one that
gives you the answer the questions
before you're tested and he tells you
when and where and now and so on nobody
else on the face of the earth doesn't
tell you the answer to the questions for
your tests and on so one day as a matter
of fact you can seal it but God Almighty
is most merciful most beneficent and the
gloves are so much that he tells us
here's what you're gonna be tested on
and here are the answers to the
questions upon Allah so he tells you of
mahalik regional area we do and I have
not created the jinn and the ants except
to worship me and how worship me of
course is that you live your whole life
according to the Quran and Sunnah and
the one that created you for the simple
fact that if you buy a car you get with
a manual and it tells the years what to
do here's what not to do so if somebody
created the car or the inventor the car
what happens if it tells you to put the
gas here the oil here and that water
here he says no I don't think you know
what you're talking about
this put the gas here the water here in
the oil here how far the car is gonna
run not very far so we're supposed to go
back to our own manual
creator that knows what's best for us
and follow Islam you'll find peace and
Sheldon is life in hereafter we know
that Islam total submission to the one
God the same way of life all the
messengers of God the Quran is a Raiden
Word of God we know these facts is not
fiction and Islam provides all the
rational logical proofs for anyone who
takes a scientific analytical approach
and praise to the one God not to a man
or woman but the Creator man and woman
that God will guide them and through
looking at all these proves they will
come to know that this is indeed from
the crater the heavens and earth so I'm
very excited because we're going to get
into the top five proofs starting from
five four three two one that the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was indeed a
Messenger of God the first part is
pretty easy because it's in their very
nature to only worship the One God not
to worship a man or the Sun or anything
in creation they can understand that
coming from all these other religions
that you know mix God with his creation
make a man to God and worshipping a
woman or man or this or that the Sun the
worshipping things that came into
existence God didn't come into existence
he's the sole creator so we only worship
Him but now the other part is was my
Prophet Muhammad a Messenger of God so
we want to give these evidences and
we're going to go in chronological order
from 5 4 3 2 1 so at the end God willing
we're going to have some people saying
the Shahada they're going to inshallah
do what's in their very nature testify
to this truth so let us start with
number 5 of the 5 proves that Muhammad
peace be upon him was indeed like Jesus
was Moses Abraham there were our
messengers and he was the last and final
messenger start with number 5 please
number 5 first of all if he put somebody
understand of course prophet mohammed
salah salem is not understand that we're
just talking hypothetically now just to
prove a case if somebody goes to court
we have to call on the witnesses so
let's call on the witnesses but we're
not going to call the witnesses do you
think we call the witnesses first as his
enemies oh so we're not calling his
mother or you know what they call his
father or his best friends people who
know we're calling his enemy right
person go ahead yeah let's start with
the enemies because al-jihad Dementyeva
lado the true one says even your staunch
enemies will testify for you so what was
he known for his enemies actually used
to call them sadha telugu I mean
the trustworthy one the truthful one
amazingly enough even in Hercules when
that was the time the caught one of the
people from his tribe because he saw a
vision and thought there would be a
messenger coming from that so he
actually talked to him some of the
people told him he says do you have
anyone that coming from his tribe or
anyone that coming close to him that was
in touch with him they found Abu Sufyan
who was at the time of the merchants
harvested here and he told him that
these people from your own tribe they
will sit behind you and they will tell
me if you're actually not telling me the
truth and of course a beefy and rajala
and he was not a Muslim then but of
course was one of the tried the
Honourable tribe and the Honourable
Society he said he didn't want it even
liked him then he started to look for
certain faults he couldn't find anything
he says well he does one two three and
they were all good yes he tries to do
good and he asked him some questions he
asked him certain questions he says
anyone in the air' peninsula called
for being a prophet before he says no
did anyone make this claim before nobody
make that claim before so the king says
if it was he maybe he was imitating
someone so he says did his own lineage
or the ancestors or Father's or
forefathers actually workings of these
areas he said no is if he was he would
have been claiming his own Kingdom back
yes and he says and so on he said what
would type of people there actually
follow me is that the poor is such were
there the prophets and he says do the
increase over the decreases the increase
is associate the prophets he says do the
people do it because therefore started
because the lovest is because they could
they're convinced as such as prophets
these were the people are not actually
Muslim this man was his enemy he could
have lied but he could have done but he
was actually telling the truth because
there was none he found a very minor
thing he says but we will see in the
future it wasn't there yet he says this
the only thing that I can actually look
for now that people actually that did
that and we will talk about the few
things a little bit later I want to not
jump the gun here but that's the first
just to quickly cover a few things
because the time will let them allow us
to go into more details now let's find
some more witness
we takin some of his enemies that
actually used to call him that he used
to entrust him with the most worldly
important decision we will talk about a
little bit later everyone knew that he
did not lie so when he says that he did
heat was he known to be a liar he says
no he says well I he by God he would not
lie he would not be truthful people on
Lyapunov law of one God Almighty if it
was known to be truthful how could he be
being truthful with people and not being
truthful with with God Almighty other
witnesses to take that one to bed he
says that now himself Prophet Muhammad
SAW solemn uncertain miracles he's done
like he fed a whole army with very
little food he that he heard he actually
was heard some some of the animals he
the the moon when it split and these
people actually saw these things even in
China and indeed he they've done that
they've seen the mood split it wasn't
the people that actually that he had
magic or spells over the people that
were there because others actually saw
these things when he had a beautiful way
to to say that the dates were actually
were overflowing last things and so many
others and the water actually came from
under his knee and that rivers have run
on water to quench the whole army he
says ash hadu anna rasoolallah at that
time he says I testified that I'm a
Messenger of God above all of the
testimonies is Allah God Almighty him
services what Lihue a shadow in the
colossal God Almighty testifies that you
are his messengers so these are just
some a sample of the testimonies that
the people come on a stand and say who
is this man and he is a Messenger of
Allah Sopranos in the future so before
we go to break the first man was her
Achilles he was a known figure in
history the people can go check this is
a man who existed and there were people
at that time that we have a chain of
narrations that are testifying to what
you just said
absolutely and abou sufyan is the one
that actually testified to that and then
him testifying himself by all these
miracles that he did and we're not
flaunting about these miracles but those
miracles were witnessed by hundreds of
his companions that we have a chain of
narrations - absolutely and then god
almighty himself in the verbatim word of
god is testifying to this and a book
that's tamper free tamper proof has been
preserved we have it today everyone
wants to take a look he's number five
that is number five the testimony so
we recapping is only number five we got
four more to go don't go nowhere okay
you put your dream home and you've got
your dream car but you're going to get
old and things are going to happen to
you in your life and then what have you
got at the end of the day it's an empty
dream that has no real foundation we are
going to dine and we're going to meet
our Lord and he is going to judge us it
becomes an obligation for each single
human being to find out what the Quran
is Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society it's killing of
innocent human beings human life is
precious
back here on the Dean show with Sheikh
Allah and we're talking about the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him we
believe as over 1.5 billion people do
that he indeed he wasn't a son of God
the right hand of God he didn't have
divinity we don't worship Muhammad but
he was indeed a Messenger of God the
same way Jesus Moses Abraham they all
were messengers of God they brought the
same message worship the Creator not his
creation and follow the messengers so go
ahead and continue with number four of
the top five that indeed proves that
Muhammad peace be upon him was indeed a
Messenger of God
take it away number four number four is
what we're talking about the message
what was his message so you have to
cross-reference what was he calling for
what's he calling people to say worship
me give me all your money
vote for me or anything else no his
message was very simple worship the one
and only God because people right there
and then they actually had 360 idols all
used to worship for thirteen years in
Mecca the Meccan era he simply says
Allah la ilaha illaallah Toffler who say
there's only one god so i may prosper
you take that simple message that
there's only one God and you
cross-reference it with every other
prophet and messenger before him you
will find out actually falls in line
with every prophet and messenger there's
only one God worship him do this to go
to heaven and don't do this so you can
stay away from the Hellfire so we ask
people what is it exactly that you don't
like about this message what makes him
not a messenger if he simply tells
people to worship God Almighty nothing
absolutely nothing in it for him as a
matter of fact people came up to him and
he said listen stop saying there's only
one God will kill you that didn't work
or stop saying there's one god of your
if you're after money we'll make you the
richest man alive that didn't work and
people came in and said if it stopped
saying there's only one god if women you
after will give you all the women you
want absolutely not they're trying to
bribe them now absolument with money or
power short in except none of it none
and he says if you want to be our King
we will make you our King if it's power
you're after we will give you the power
if it's voodoo that you have we'll give
you the best Exorcist if it's an illness
that you have we'll get you the best
doctors he listened as you will see
later on how we listened is are you
finished even
the perfect addition is weak we
understand that but the Syrah is not
dealt with accordingly to that camp or
the rulings so he says if you put the
Sun in my right hand and the moon in my
left hand I will not stop saying there's
only one god or die for it so he wasn't
after his own whims and desires as a
matter of fact he died as a poor man may
peace and blessings of God Almighty be
on to him and he could have been the
richest man he could have had everything
and of course people have so many things
to accuse or abuse and shall hopefully
we can give you that the knowledge of
the proper way of who Prophet Muhammad
may peace be upon him there was so that
number four is for the simple fact that
is the message what is this message is
that for the simple fact that is only
one God it coincides with everybody else
before him my fact comes back and
rectifies what was misinterpreted or
diverted or let us stray before him go
back to the original the message was
very simple there's only one God worship
Him and that coincides and with in line
with every prophet and messenger and
makes sense and he's received it of
course from the Archangel Gabriel so the
message was very simple straightforward
there's only one God which makes him a
prophet five four take it away with
three go ahead number three now we
talked about the message
now let's cross-reference now what is
the actual message the message came from
the Quran so the Quran because every
prophet and messenger has a miracle to
prove their lead over his messenger than
the Prophet and so on so we take a look
at the Quran in itself for every prophet
has the messenger so like we say Moses
may peace be upon him had the the
miracle of the staff because at the time
that people like to magic and so on
however an insights let may peace be
upon him Jesus may peace be upon him I
also had that the miracle of medicine
because at that time it pertained to
these type of people and they were into
that type of thing yes but when God
Almighty challenged the Arabs because
the language was the strength he
actually used to teach people poetry and
he says a man came up to me says I can't
remember how many records how many units
of prayer to do so the man came up to
him is listen I'll give you a poem he
will understand he said in the Salah
thought about far back
that is our bathroom at 11 he says for
them forth and three then for them too
he got it for a poetry and they were
challenged with their own because they
were used to boast about how eloquent
they are and they and the genius of the
language and the science of the language
that they had undergone so God Almighty
said actually that the earth here is
this book that is going to be in your
own language and if Lam Meem
alif-lam-mim these are the letters that
this book is made of their little key
tab here is the book who delimit attain
guidance those who have piety or
conscious of God so God Almighty
challenged him in their own field that
God Almighty actually told them in that
Quran which is a live language we have
the original we never lost it it was
memorized written at the time of the
life of prophet mohammed salah salem and
no one can deny the fact that we do not
differ upon it and we have the miracles
and we talked about the scientific
miracles update and so many others and
we heard this from chakali the scenes
along HIDA wants to prove to you from
this fact that we actually memorizes
preserved as Allah as God Almighty has
promised to preserve the Quran he said
that if all denominations are always of
life for all religions agreed to throw
all the scriptures all the divine
scriptures in the ocean to just get rid
of them get rid of them
we all agreed to get rid of all the
divine scriptures which is the only one
book that will come back to life and
immediately the only answer is the Quran
because we memorize it off by heart no
one can differ upon it and this is
something that we do from that from very
early stages and whether you speak
Arabic or not the people actually
memorize the Quran so no one can
actually defy that the actual miracle of
the Quran in itself that has their news
from what the past's how to live your
life in the present and what will come
in that future
and that message we talked about the
oneness of God Almighty is actually one
third of the Quran one third of the
Quran so when the people say that to
what is the message of the Quran the
oneness of God is one third of it and
when people say that this Quran that
comes from Satanic Verses amazingly
enough what I have these people coming
into the center when I have these tours
it's all I'm okay
let's go with that let's go with the
idea that what Arabella we seek refuge
out from that it's a you know Satanic
Verses you've heard okay Satan is the
author of the Quran
so it's interesting because in the Quran
it says when you read the cornet occur
at one first and blemish on origin when
you recite the Quran seek refuge in God
from Satan the rejected can you imagine
Satan is the author of the book says
hmmm before you read my book seek refuge
in God from me and I forget to mention a
few things if you follow me you go
straight to help oh yes I am your worst
enemy go ahead buy my book imagine
imagine that's the case when people
actually say that these are Satanic
Verses
or the other ones it says that it is
Mohammed that wrote the book amazing
don't you know that actually Prophet
Muhammad may peace be upon him did not
know how to read it right
surprise interestingly enough that
Prophet Muhammad may peace one did not
know how to read a right Oh me me was
that actually comes from the mother the
word oome it was that taught by that
nature primal instinct he was not taught
and these people accuse him for actually
taken over from others as a matter of
fact we know that the Bible has been
translated on the 18th century it wasn't
at the time of a Prophet Muhammad may
peace bottom just in case that people
think that he was actually trying to
copy wholesale from the Bible and not to
mention that ease verses there is a very
challenging verses as we talked about it
before and the Quran in itself the Quran
itself has a challenge a challenging
people that stand the test of time there
was a challenge at the time of the
revelation that god almighty says
believe it or not to the uncle of
Prophet Muhammad may peace but him that
he will not go to he will not become a
Muslim even then he knew that for years
while he was alive he could have simply
said well guess what I want to become a
Muslim what do you think of your Koran
now he didn't and of course there are
other ones other miracles of the Quran
that actually testified that says Oliver
to Rome the word right there the Roman
were actually beaten it says the
government says women better develop
inside Llewyn and after the being
defeated
there will be victorious people
reasoning if you a few day if you
years so these were miracles on hand
there testifies and again God Almighty
give the people a challenge as we
mentioned previously says listen if you
want to prove this book it's not from
God Almighty you do this if you do this
file this book under G with at the villa
and he will tell you would gives you
another challenge you will never be able
to do this with the Quran since you will
never believe this but that will not let
you go this would be stay away from the
quiet so this is one verse or one
chapter or two chapters and that stand
the test still stands up till now this
is God Almighty the creator speaking
absolutely offering a challenge to
mankind right so we went from five four
three we got two and one left don't go
nowhere why we give you the five top
reasons why problem Hamid peace be upon
is deed indeed a messenger from the
creator of the heavens and earth sit
tight deaf and the day of judgment the
mercy of Allah these are the things that
finally made me realize there is no time
to delay anymore
I want you to take martial heart right
there agree the essence of spirituality
is to become more sincere to Allah spend
whatever but to play death itself it is
very very scary but it brings you back
to reality there is a life which is
everlasting and you have to make a
conscious decision of which a group of
people do you want to be off leaving
heaven over the people of hell alone
back here on the D show top five reasons
why problem Hamid peace be upon him is
indeed a Messenger of God there is no
God worthy of worship except the one God
the one creator of all that exists and
as we said if you're living during
Jesus's time he was a Messenger of God
you had to testify that he was your
teacher a message to teaching you how to
get close to God you didn't worship Him
or pray to him nor did you do that to
any of the messages right so we don't
worship Muhammad but indeed we follow
his teachings the same way we to follow
Jesus as Moses Abraham's teaching but
he's the last and final messenger so
we're giving you the proofs so you will
know that he is indeed a message your
guy went from five four three please
take it away with number two okay
speaking of that much if even Prophet
Muhammad's life says let alone II do not
boast about me but say about me that I
am do not say that I am the son of God
or God incarnate or divine or so on I am
a human being just like you the
differences I receive revelations now
where the topic we're talking about now
number
for is a clap moral conduct behavior
etiquettes manners god almighty
testifies in the quran he says gives
them this beautiful medal of honor is
what in nikita salopin Alim indeed you
are the best of moral conduct behaviors
because we have to walk the talk every
human being is a there's a measuring
stick god almighty says that he is the
best of moral conduct as a matter of
fact he says I am sent to complete the
best of moral conduct and so on one of
the reasons that we have to do this
cross reference is to cross it from the
book what God Almighty testifies that he
is his message was this the Quran says
do these things it's all about enjoying
good and forbidding evil how to be the
best human beings that even so the some
of the scholar says that the acts of
worship in the Quran actually to give
you a better moral conduct and for
example is that the fasting is actually
to talk about taqwa give you a LeCompte
attack on the Salah is warded off evil
there's a cache to teach you to give the
word to heal you from the illness of the
hoarding the silver and gold the illness
of the heart and being Hajj it teaches
you patience so you understand that
every aspect of our worship is to become
a better human being
so Prophet Muhammed SAS Allah is the
best of creations so you walk the talk
and how was it then if when Prophet
Muhammad may peace be upon him when
people wanted to kill him even though
they did not believe in his message they
still trusted with him with the most
worldly possession the most expensive
one even though that he wanted the knew
about it you and I asking you brothers
and sisters out there now put yourself
in that position if somebody wants to
kill you but you have something of their
own what would you do I'm pretty sure
you say you don't you know what you're
talking to you want to mess with me and
so on
no I now I've confiscated your stuff but
it wasn't for Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu send them because he was the
best of creation he says yeah Ali his
cousin he says you stay here but when
you wake up in the morning you give them
back their rightful owners and he taught
us let Akuma ha do not betray this will
betray you be good to those who are bad
to you give those who deprive you reach
for those who
and so on as a matter of fact he was a
lead in so many moral conduct and ethics
that he had a young girl that wanted to
come and join him in a toast atutor to
witness a war and he actually after the
war he was looking for someone this
young girl's actually in the rating this
prophetic tradition and he says as if he
was looking for me and he had this
pelada this beautiful necklace as the
spoils of war and she ran and she ran
Timmy says here I am Here I am a
Messenger of Allah a sort of Salaam and
he said he put that on her on her own he
says by Allah I will never take this
necklace from my own neck anymore and
she put in her well that she wanted to
be buried with this necklace and on
Judgment Day she wants to run to him it
says ya rasulallah Oh merciful Allah so
Salam can you remember me I am the one
that you put this necklace this necklace
you see how we actually talked to the
young high he actually had a young boy
called the way and he had a bird called
the weight and he actually used to rock
up higher on my house in waves this bird
one day is on crying he stayed with him
what happened is methanol ate a nobody
that bird died he stayed with him to
leave him with a smile on his face as he
saw him with a tear in his eyes
I understand there's so much to share
under comes two o'clock but even though
when a man promised to meet him at a
certain time because he wanted to keep a
covenant and be truthful to others after
two days he waited for him is his
attacked any I waited for you and so
many others we cannot comprehend the
amount of moral conduct that Prophet
Muhammad may peace be upon him was known
for how to deal with human beings not
only human beings even animals and every
others may bestow job five four three
two and we're almost coming to an end
let's take it away with the number one
proof evidence that indeed Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was a mighty
Messenger of God so we said the proof
the proof is in the pudding so we say
the fruit of this whole thing so when we
talk about you know the testimony of
people when we talk about the message
when we talk about the Quran when we
talk about the moral conduct as you walk
to talk of everything so now what is the
outcome the fruit this whole thing look
at it started with one human being this
whole almost
with one Prophet Muhammad may peace pond
it is now 1.54 1.7 billion Muslims
around the world saying there's only one
God declaring this being good staying
away from evil declaring enjoining good
forbidding evil trying to change their
life to better do living their life
according to modesty humbleness and all
these beauty of the teaching of Islam
how to help one another how to have the
humanity being come on a straight path
the unity the oneness and regardless of
people of color creed and face you are
my brethren in humanity as we mentioned
earlier Allah subhana WA Ta'ala than
that so look at the fruit of this look
at the fruit of Muslims and we say that
we understand that we're no we're No
Angels we're human being just like
everybody else but I'm talking about
those who practice Islam those who
actually live and walk the talk like
Prophet Muhammad may peace pon him when
Aisha may be a member may God be pleased
with her when she was asked about how
was he he was a walking Quran so now how
it changed the human being those who
actually used to kill one another are
now being bonded the fruit of that is
the Quran and the message of Prophet
Muhammad may be upon him and of course
every history will testify that no
migration has taken place without
bloodshed
the only migration that did not take
bloodshed with the migrants from queca
that went to Medina fell and sorrow and
help one another and that's another
topic on its own it's going to take
another hour to explain but I'm not
going to go into details but you see how
God a'mighty
change and the message of the fruit for
those people that used to kill one
another now become both bosom buddies
those who actually used to drink alcohol
fornicate and marry different women and
all women that wants to have any
intimate relations with anyone and claim
that child to be that man now has
changed and restricted certain things
give away the slavery turning this whole
humanity around to be the best of human
beings to be truthful and honest get rid
of way of the usury and all these moral
conducts is a fruit of Islam from the
Quran and Sunnah and not in a nutshell
there's so much to share but just to
give you an example for the
one-two-three-and-four-and-five
is the proof is in the pudding as you
will see those who actually established
Islam in their life are the best of
human beings accordingly even in the
Bible mentioned you will know that from
the fruit
and that is the best of teaching of
Islam thank you very much we're out of
time because you're going to go ahead
and talk about this for hours and hours
we only had a little bit time and you
explained it so I look Whitney thank you
so much may Allah the Creator that
heavens earth rewards you you too a fee
thank you for having me thank you once
again for tuning in to the Deen show
Islam is not about terrifying or
terrorizing people Islam is not what all
the hype has been created about to go
ahead and establish injustice Islam is
about bringing justice bringing peace
into a human beings life and you got to
hear all these wonderful proofs to
provide you the human being who's
searching for the purpose of life there
is a day of judgment we all be
accountable for we did on this life and
at the end there's a paradise and
there's a Hellfire and everything has
been laid out the blueprint it's been
set with this last and final messenger
who was sent to all of mankind as a
mercy to the world as a mercy to the
world that if you follow his teachings
as we said the same way if you would
have followed Jesus's teachings he was
the way the truth and the light but no
in no way did he ever claim that he was
God the Son of God and all this other
stuff no they all call people to worship
the one God so when you sit back and you
analyze all these proofs with a open
mind a humble heart you will indeed see
that indeed this is from the Creator
that have is an earth and how you can be
successful is by living this truth and
we hope that now that you've gotten to
learn more and you can call the number
on the screen 1 800 662 Islam if you
want to accept Islam if you want to join
the family of over 1.5 billion people
worldwide and until next time peace be
unto you and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the religions I remember finding out the
meaning of what Islam is what Muslim is
those who surrender their self to God is
a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will
Daisy Islam was pure it was just you
just pray to God your Creator I am Not
Afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if allies by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone
I'm not afraid to stand alone